so last night was the second night of
the democratic national convention we
had a live stream for the full two hours
there was the sort of formal
nomination process of joe biden with
each state casting their delegates
uh proportionally or 100 for different
candidates and
it was a significantly better night than
night one without question
there were fewer of these energy sucking
moments where after like an okay speech
they would cut to
low energy smooth jazz or something like
that
it was better put together there were
actually some very interesting moments
headlined by
joe biden's wife dr jill biden who did
the last speech of the night who i
realized
in watching her she would be a better
president
than donald trump forget about joe biden
for a moment
i was trying to think is there any issue
where if you said
david we need either donald trump or
jill
biden to figure out this issue is there
any issue where i would pick donald
trump and there really isn't
i mean even on coronavirus quite frankly
it's hard to imagine anyone doing a
worse job than
trump on the virus but as a doctor of
education
jill biden would just understand oh it's
a medical situation oh well we need to
let doctors take the lead rather than
than donald trump for example but i'm
heading
getting ahead of myself a little bit
here one of the best moments
was one of the best lines of the night
really was former secretary
of state john kerry referring to donald
trump's overseas trips as blooper reels
take a look at this
donald trump inherited a growing economy
and a more peaceful world
and like everything else he inherited he
bankrupted it
when this president goes overseas it
isn't a goodwill mission it's a blooper
reel
he breaks up with our allies and writes
love letters to dictators
america deserves a president who is
looked up to
not laughed at that actually made me
laugh in in the moment and john kerry
uh was was quite good at laying out the
importance of voting
uh for joe biden and to remove donald
trump in november bill clinton also
spoke and it was fine
there was debate about whether bill
clinton should speak or maybe instead it
should be al gore
who is sort of a direct testament to
what happens when not enough people vote
and you end up winning the popular vote
losing the electoral college and
changing the course of history maybe al
gore should have spoken instead maybe al
gore
should have spoken in addition to bill
clinton we heard from congresswoman
alexandria ocasio-cortez in a much
anticipated speech it was very short
she formally nominated bernie sanders to
be the nominee there were some people
who said oh it's a snub
it was really a formality bernie was set
to receive delegates from some states so
someone has to nominate him
it was not a snub it was rather
procedural and
nbc news took some heat because they
misreported
what alexandria ocasio-cortez did and
they made a big deal out of it
i'm not going to since it really wasn't
a big deal and i don't want to play
into that but we did hear from aoc and
then yeah dr jill biden let's take a
look at just a little bit of her speech
and you'll see
this is the wrap up and you'll see joe
biden come out and embrace her if you're
watching and you'll hear him say just a
few words
if you are listening i know that if we
entrust this nation to joe
he will do for your family what he did
for ours bring us together
and make us whole carry us forward
in our time of need keep the promise
of america for all of us
hey everyone i'm jill biden's husband
as you heard tonight excuse me you can
see why she's the love of my life
the rock of our family she never gives
herself much credit
but the truth is she's the strongest
person i know she's a backbone like a
ramrod
she loves fiercely cares deeply nothing
stops her when she sets her mind into
getting something right
so yeah i mean it's all pretty cheesy
this this isn't the type of packaging
that appeals to me
this isn't the type of political event
that appeals to me
but it doesn't matter i'm not the target
here and realistically
neither are you realistically anybody
who is
watching the david pakman show on
youtube listens to political podcasts if
you listen to the podcast
you're not the target you you've already
decided right and so i think it's
important for us to keep that in mind
but i have to say
when you hear about and learn about
the tragedy of joe biden's life losing
his first wife and child
in a car accident and then you hear
about jill biden
becoming a mother to joe biden's two
sons while she was in graduate school
you just see the way the bidens relate
to each other it is a reminder because
of the stark contrast that's in the
white house right now
about how absurd the trump
administration and trump as president is
on a personal level melania seems to
hate trump
some of trump's kids seem to hate him
trump
seems to think some of his kids are
idiots like not none of this is normal
and obviously we can separate
you know if their politics are great who
cares about their home lives
in this particular case with donald
trump it's all related
and it's all very very bad the same
delusions of grandeur and narcissism
that make his f a personal life and
family life a disaster
make his administration a disaster and
that was
you know i i didn't really need the
convention because the choices are so
crystal clear for me this time around
but i do think that this second night
particularly with dr jill biden and some
of the backstory on joe biden's life
i do think it actually was far better
put together
than night number one so tonight we're
going to be hearing from
senator elizabeth warren which i'm very
much looking forward to again
as someone who competed against joe
biden in the democratic primary this
year
we heard from by uh bernie on monday
night
making the case that if you supported
bernie in 2016 if you supported bernie
in 2020
here is why it is so important to vote
for joe biden in november
i'm interested to see how elizabeth
warren
puts together a sort of similar argument
i'm not as much
looking forward to hearing from nancy
pelosi and hillary clinton tonight
although i think it will be interesting
to see what approach they take
and whether they play to the left or
they play to the middle or what they do
we're going to hear from former
congresswoman grab gabby giffords who
is a tragically was a victim of gun
violence years ago
and also headlining tonight we will hear
from vice presidential candidate
kamala harris and we're also going to
hear from former president barack obama
all leading up to the final night
tomorrow
when we will hear from the nominee
himself
joe biden and it's much anticipated
for different reasons by different
people the right is anticipating joe
biden's speech
with the idea that he's going to be
barely coherent and
unable to put together anything sensible
or sensical
whereas i'm interested in seeing what is
the
approach in order to bring people in
in other words centrists center left
disaffected republicans progressive
leftists former bernie people
so on and so forth so i will see you
tonight
at 8 45 pm eastern time on youtube
twitch
and or facebook your preference uh for
the start of night three
and um we will be back of course
tomorrow with analysis and preparation
for the final night of the democratic
national convention
and then we have to get ready for the
republican national convention happening
next week